[Music]
not a lot guys this is another not so
fun article oh
is it on patreon though can't wait for
steve day when when's all steve day god
damn we're gonna turn this one around
promote your own yeah my own hosting
hosting
i was like what's all steve day oh yeah
it's tomorrow okay like it's a shark
week
[Laughter]
a disabled death row inmate do you have
to add that yeah well should i not
describe that he's disabled it's like
part of the information well if he's a
death row inmate maybe he got there
because of good reasons over here we
view everyone as able you know what's
crazy though i was i was about to be a
juror for this um
trial and
there was like the defendant was in a
wheelchair and he got in trouble for
stabbing somebody in lancaster
at a sizzler so it's like how did he
even get there maybe he used he was a
battering ram
he [ __ ] got a sword out like that and
then someone pushed him i think it was a
stick knife and he just was like
and this is and this is why nick wasn't
on the jury he went up to the judge he's
like sorry i can't be on this i think
the wheelchair guy was right yeah
i think that the other guy deserved it
the guy should have seen him coming
and so monkey jousting at that point
armed with a deadly [ __ ]
sword yeah
so what's his disability uh
again this is this is uh this is a bit
of a sad story
great disabled death wrote inmate ate
his final meal and prayed for mercy
before his lethal injection injection uh
this is an arizona man and the ironic
thing well i guess i don't know it's
ironic maybe it's just coincidence but
this is actually the second lethal
injection execution in the month and
they haven't done one like eight years
um this guy was
he he had uh murdered an eight-year-old
girl
uh by the name of vicki lynn hoskinson
in 1984. okay um this [ __ ] long time
dude just kill the guy listen roll him
off a [ __ ] bridge or something dude
the only time you're gonna hear me say
the only time you're going to hear me
say the words lethal injection during
all steam day will involve a man's penis
into a [ __ ] vagina let's go
believe all women as well
i believe all women as well just got a
tackling man you gotta tag it all right
uh his name is frank atwood
age 66
he was put to death at the state prison
in florence arizona after the u.s
supreme court cleared the way for his
execution having rejected a final appeal
by his lawyers and his legal team argued
that atwood who was in a wheelchair
would undergo excruciating suffering
strapped to the gurney while lying on
his back due to his degenerative spinal
condition thus violating his
constitutional right against cruel and
unusual well this is a thing right
because because um the way that they do
the lethal injection they've shown that
the method or like what they use
actually does provide pain
to the person's body like on their way
out and the dead
he couldn't choose another route uh oh
so you actually have the choice so two
weeks probably death by suffocation it
was it was a choice between lethal
injection or the gas chamber and
apparently this happens from time to
time but he couldn't make a choice okay
i i wish that if i get gas chamber it
smells good because i'm imagining gas
chambers smells like sulfur
is it i don't want to die like
oh you know i want to die like imagine
coconut imagine that bread
a sponsorship where it's like gas
chamber brought to you by glade
regret you always have do you guys get
uh
kind of yeah how hard time choosing when
you're at a car wash and then they have
a [ __ ] menu of choices like you're
buying a snow cone they got like coconut
pina colada oh for this one you like i
like black ice yeah
that's what i like
short menus straight to the point yeah
do you hear that do you think that if
glade did that the guy in charge of
marketing would get fired because
they're like who are you marketing to
he's about to die you [ __ ] idiot and
he's like oh my god i didn't even know
they're not televised i don't even think
about that and it's a limited market
yeah stupid idiot there's like only five
people you gotta buy a lot though you
gotta buy a lot to make the room smell
that's true
it's gonna make headlines you know what
i mean
every outlet's plugged into everything
yeah he's one of those uh loose cannon
marketers
on every paper in the town it's just a
bunch of glade plugins in this room he's
like the money ball of blade plug-in
advertising there's a niche
we can make our money back the roi is
gonna be crazy
speaking on the pain of lethal
injections arizona had put executions on
hiatus
after the botched lethal injection of
joseph wood in 2014 when a process that
should have taken 10 minutes
lasted almost two hours but isn't that
kind of cool if they if they did
something
like it i think cruel and unusual is the
worst it's not me
it's cool and unusual oh cool
you know what
cool and unusual punishment i like that
joe's kind of cool kind of a maverick
just put oakley's on you before you
that's like yo that dude now you look
cool
babe you put a place on you and they
give you a foam number one
well they [ __ ] inject your ass
they're like there's no injection or gas
chamber joe's like uh lethal injection
for two hours
please thank you
because i'm always thinking about the
victim right and i'm like wasn't it
cruel and unusual what they did to the
victim
and then so they can't get a taste of
their own [ __ ] medicine it's hard for
me to feel empathetic for a guy who
killed an eight-year-old right i hope
that's not a hot day i don't have any
[ __ ] empathy for like kid murderers
roll this guy off a [ __ ] cliff cruel
and unusual so this is uh
somebody had tweeted that give him a
little swift kick this is what frankie
is what frank atwood did he's slated for
execution arizona today thinking of
vicki hoskinson and her family give him
two you know give him dude it's not bad
and then they've got [ __ ] the beers
on the side with the hat dude what was
this that's okay it's okay let's keep
talking about beer no no what was that
what was that
he's got the [ __ ] beer
it was poison
cool and unusual
you know that's a good brand cool cool
and unusual it could be a good clothing
brand yeah cool and unusual punishment
dude but the fact that it's just like
a foam thing that's what makes everybody
cool though that looks like a [ __ ]
t-shirt you get in like hawaii abc
supermarket like cool and unusual right
next to the [ __ ] number one finger
hawaii abc store right next to an eight
dollar water bro that's great
like 35 sunscreen give me the macadamia
chocolates and the cool and unusual
t-shirts like cool like no problem it's
it'll be 178 dollars
dude that's the cover for [ __ ]
newsweek the new look of death row
what is this that's the new look of
death row
dude uncovered
so anthony what was the picture you
showed us
nah it's sad it was it was a picture of
the funeral there's a funeral vic vicky
yeah dude [ __ ] that guy who cares yeah
that guy sucks is that crazy though like
to think like uh all right you're on
death row so you're like the attorney
right of the guy who's on death row and
you're like um honestly you can't be
killing him yet like that's [ __ ] up
that you're gonna like lie him down
because he's got a degenerate spinal
disease and it's gonna hurt him [ __ ] man
dude yeah maybe that's god bless him how
about like put him out of his misery if
he's in pain
i know certain states have the like uh
you have three people in a room who will
shoot at the person who's on death row
and they have like a blindfold firing
squad yeah a firing squad and you don't
the three people are shooting don't know
who has the bullet yeah so they don't
necessarily know who killed him they
don't have the guilt but like that's
another way to go out [ __ ] absolute
[ __ ] so what happens to the person who
has a bullet didn't know they had the
bullet shot didn't shoot a lethal shot
yeah shot the [ __ ] tip of his
shoulder
shot his dick someone should get out of
the ball
[Laughter]
the tip of the foam finger
he
that's so [ __ ] dark and morbid i love
it that's so cool and unusual thank you
it works it works i really like that i
think why why do they protect people
that have done some crazy [ __ ] so much
don't you want to get into another type
of law if you're an attorney
you gotta do a good job there to move up
right is that is that kind of like just
being a [ __ ] you know a pa you know
like
it's like hey dude i really want to get
in the film yeah you go get me some
[ __ ] coffee yeah yeah it's like hey
you're gonna back this guy up yeah and
if you could do a good job
oh you could represent johnny imagine
it's like it's like hey my client list
yes most of them died due to lethal
injection however
i'm gonna do killer this time i promise
you i'll do real good well they did that
to camille vazquez they're like oh my
god johnny duff's still gonna lose hey
camille you take this case
imagine that [ __ ] [ __ ] it up wins gets
promoted becomes partner
i feel like you gotta do these cases
before you go to the johnny depp cases
yeah that's where everyone wants that's
like the [ __ ] oscar feature film
level [ __ ] well it's not like that's a
bot attorney that's gotta be a public
defender can i do johnny depp today no
no no you're doing a death row inmate
who's disabled get him off the hook and
we'll see about tomorrow yeah
then then we'll see if you make partners
by the way he's got beer cans on the
side of his head and a foam finger don't
[ __ ] with the phone thing that's how
unreasonably fair this country is
she's like goddammit another cool and
unusual
my third one this week the [ __ ]
oakleys god damn it
what are their cool sunglasses companies
we could think of no other gray bands
oakley's it is white ray bands bro you
want you want cool
oakleys
you want cool that's the new tagline you
want cool
eau claire dude give me put them on give
them these glasses that have the it's
like attached to
the the crazy straps yeah the crazy
straws
so it goes around your eyes the neon
yellow
drinking some milk so you see the liquid
go through
that's how the injective it goes through
that thing little gesture that you can
see because they're going through funny
glasses how about some lethal ejection
that even kids can see just spice it up
a little yeah
and put this in here after they put it
in here they start wrapping it around
your face like a [ __ ] balloon
why is it gonna be so dark is all we're
saying
[ __ ] funny dude the ivy goes like
this ty likes some balloons to his
wheelchair we're good it doesn't just go
around your eyes got the big sh log too
just [ __ ] cool and unusual bro
i mean
it used to be a family event to watch
witches burn at the stake or people get
uh don't families still go to [ __ ]
lethal injections i would dude families
were there for the first shot of the
civil war laying on [ __ ] picnic yep
blankets and [ __ ] stop talking about
your grandpa again
and then he was killing them all
right kill them all kill them good yeah
he killed all the asians in the civil
war too
dude war used to be a thing where like
all the rich people would just
pull up and then just watch it was your
version of ufc used to you never seen an
asian in the civil war did you
there's a reason for that his
grandfather
they're actually you set that up piece
of [ __ ] i recently saw this thing there
was a [ __ ] chinese dude that was
fighting in the civil war i don't know
if he was i don't know what you're doing
kung fu got shot in the first 10 minutes
yeah that would suck to be forced to
[ __ ] you think he's like i don't i
don't want no trouble
and then just jabs
no [ __ ] he can't stop automatically
kicking ass like jackie chan movie no i
just saw this i'm going to reload i
barely know how i'm doing this
that's my jacket he's using his jacket
to [ __ ] everybody
with a bucket tied to a rope dude
imagine you go to the smithsonian
there's just a jacket and they're like
this is the jacket that what the [ __ ]
warriors
i think you guys are talking about the
tuxedo with jackie chan in it yeah oh
yeah no we're talking about every jackie
chamber yeah he's always killing
somebody with a jacket or there's a
random refrigerator that he's hitting
five people yes dude you know what i
mean his name is not jacket chad grabs a
frying pan like he's never seen one in
his whole life he picks it up he's like
what the [ __ ] is this and he [ __ ]
uses it as a weapon and he's blocking
bullets look look at this [ __ ] are you
guys seeing everything everywhere all at
once
all right his name is joseph pierce one
of the only chinese americans who fought
in the book
his name is pierce but he looks fooled
chinese yeah adopted by it sounds like
my grandpa missed a spot huh
wow
wow he wasn't even born yet wow
like i said your joke
[Music]